Hi everyone, so let's go ahead and recap some of the things that we talked about in this
course. We talked about lighting optimization, analyzing scenes and priority areas, baking
versus dynamic overview. We also looked at Lumen overall, the equation of what to tackle
and how to get things done using key workflows, limitations, quality control, optimizing and
editing. We also did a review of Lightmass Baking, CPU and GPU, looking at Lightmass
Baking CPU review, overall setting up pre-computed lighting scenarios review, as well as GPU
Lightmass review. We also took a look at Screen Space Global Illumination, using Screen Space
for Final Pixel, and using Screen Space Global Illumination for ICBFX. We looked at some
helpful CVARS in that direction also. We also took a look at Ray Tracing Review, we looked
at optimizing for Final Pixel review, and optimizing for ICBFX dual workflows. And then
finally we looked at optimizing Fog Effects, what to look for, and optimizing settings to
get you in the right direction. Well, I hope you've enjoyed this series of videos and lessons,
and they will add to your project and you'll make great stuff. Thanks again and have a
great day.